Hello everybody.
Oh my I am tired Oh my gosh Hello I just want you guys to
know Um when I Uh for when this was all over Um yesterday I
think I slept like 18 hours I was
like awake and then I like back asleep okay all right okay
guys okay this is so embarrassing okay today i was still
really tired i think it's because like everything just came
crashing down on me like i was just like you know i was like
using reserve energy to do everything until rest of tuber
was over and then i actually started hibernating okay i'm
gonna tell you guys a very embarrassing story it's not even
It's not even a story, but it's so embarrassing.
It's a little TMI.
I'll just But we're homies, but like guys, I just need you
guys to know This is a very embarrassing thing.
I'm going to tell you guys, but like I have to let you guys
know how tired I was So I'm just gonna give you guys what
this is so please do not laugh at me
You guys are no regard never mind you guys will laugh at me
regardless.
Yeah, it's okay I understand why anyway, this was how tired
I was Um, I woke up today I woke up I was like, alright Like
yesterday I didn't even eat dinner That's how yesterday I,
this is not the embarrassing part yet I was so tired Uh from
everything that I didn't even eat Dinner yesterday I just
like Went to sleep I just went to sleep before dinner
Yesterday and then I woke up And then I was like, okay, oh I
should get something to eat like oh my gosh it's I don't
remember what time I woke up I just know like it's morning
it's the day out it's today it's morning and then I was like
oh man I'm so I should get I wasn't really hungry at that
time but I was like I should get something to eat because I
didn't have dinner I might as well eat like brunch or
something and so I went to the bathroom and I went back to
bed because I used up all my energy and I fell asleep
I was like okay but first I really needs the bathroom and
after I finished using the bathroom I went back to bed and
was like oh my gosh I'm so tired from all that energy I used
up and
And so, and so, I fell back asleep and then I woke up at
like, I think I woke up at like 2 p.m.
That's, that's how tired, that's how tired I was.
Oh yeah, I really wore myself there.
Um, um, but I just, that's how, that's, that's when you know
it.
I was very tired I still am I still am I'm pretty sure after
this stream I'm gonna go take a nap again just to like
recharge my battery glad me thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you Cosmic thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you oh I'm not gonna read that message
Cosmic but thank you um I think it was a success I think
WrestleTuber was uh was a huge success Well, I don't know if
I should say huge success, but I think WrestleTuber did do,
um, did like, uh, oh my gosh, my, sorry, my brain is like
processing words.
I can't words right now.
But I think like WrestleTuber did go as how I wanted and
beyond that because it feels like I think you guys all
enjoyed it.
I think you guys, all, every single one of you guys enjoyed,
uh, WrestleTuber and like all the nice surprises and
everything.
Um, and it just, it felt like, and then I'm having like so
many different storylines uh so many different storylines
being played out and all the and you do know all of it was
like ai right like everything was controlled by ai like the
the wrestlers but holy shit i don't know how but like i
don't know how we were so lucky with the ai like went in the
end because some of you guys were like oh joki you purposely
made usans wrestler overpowered as hell so like betto was
gonna lose no matter what no actually i wasn't i i it was
the same i told them to make it the same stat i was like it
has to be the same as everybody else so i have no idea how
the fuck betto got smacked so hard that he died outside of
the ring like it's so fucking fast like that surprised me so
much because i was definitely not expecting to the point
where he literally i'm like i think his ai actually died for
like he stopped moving and then i was like there's no way
No, hey, get up, pedo.
Get the fuck up.
That was fucking crazy.
I couldn't believe that happened.
It was like, it was so perfect.
The pedo was tired.
It was a pedo's turn to be eepy.
Hmm.
But yeah, both Yuson and Betta are getting belts sent over.
It was originally planned.
Because people were like, no, Betta lost his belt.
It's not fair.
But Wesley's not fair, baby.
Welcome to WWE.
Flynn was never fair.
Well, listen, people were saying, like, oh my god, it gave,
like, John Cena versus...
What's his name?
The guy that plays Drax and Guardians of the Galaxy.
Batista, oh my god, I'm gonna fucking butcher his name,
Guardians and Guardians of the Cow, Batista, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, Batista, you were saying, no, it's
just like the John Cena versus Batista match all over again,
and like, true, no, I'll show you guys the clip, it's
literally basically what happened, um, with what I did to,
what I did to the battle is basically uh what happened in
wwe it was almost the same fitting um i'm basically the ceo
of wrestle tuber but like the one that the the type of ceo
that doesn't get arrested not like i would not like to be
compared to the ceo to the ex ceo of wwe because he got
arrested for things I am not that type.
Too soon.
Bro, that happened in January.
That was like fucking sick.
Almost six months ago, guys.
Like, it's not too soon.
Nam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The best part for me alongside seeing the Fable, Doki, and
Mint collab was being introduced to so many new people.
I went from not knowing Nana to joining her membership.
just one example.
Thank you, the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I think that is why I really wanted to do these types
of events, because like, this is what, like, we're missing
in the, um, in the NA, like, uh, and not just NA, but I
would say, like, because, you know, so we had, like,
Europeans joining, uh, WrestleTuber, and, uh, also not just
Europeans, but also people from Asia joining, uh, people
from Asia joining WrestleTuber.
But, like, I feel like this is what were missing in the
English side in the like Western VTuber scene with like
events that unite like different air different companies
different fan bases in these corporate um sorry I choked on
water a little earlier so I but muted so you guys didn't
know but in these corporate and everything just like smaller
smaller channels and big channels working together in like a
very fun event and I felt like that was something we were
missing we were missing that in the western side of e-tubing
and this was something i've always wanted to do it has
always been on my roadmap to have something that was open to
like uh different companies and i was really happy to be
able to do it and i was really happy i was able to plan
something like this um and being able to invite so many
people joining in as well um i reached out to a lot of
people sending invites out um and i i didn't really uh and i
wanted like you know different like even though there might
be small vtubers i also wanted them to have a chance uh
especially with like x prism um i was happy to invite them
over i think i think like x prism was like the first the
first group of people i invited to wrestle tuber they were
the first invites i sent out i'm pretty sure um and from
there i sent out invites to all the other companies and also
the Indies as well.
Lita, thank you for the Aka Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Congratulations on your first big event, Doki.
It sounds like you're working so hard.
Please look after yourself.
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Next week, I'm definitely gonna let's chill next week.
Most likely, I will have, like, a rest week for next week.
So it was because this week I couldn't really chill yet, uh,
because I did have, like, prior obligations that I had to
do, uh, especially with the Rust stuff, um, because the Rust
thing is ending on the 31st, and I felt bad because, you
know, they invited me, it's a huge Rust streaming server,
like, a lot of the big names are part of it, and I got,
like, the, like, the invite to join, um, and, like, you
know, there's not a lot of YouTubers in there, too, so I
thought I was like, oh, this is such a rare invite to join
the server so I was like oh fuck I should do at least one
day I should try out I should try yeah the rust kingdom I
was like oh man I should I should try at least one day
there's always texting there isn't though that's the thing
rust the rust server is ending like literally in three days
so it's ending on the 31st so I was like oh man I need to do
at least one day look just check it out uh let's thank you
for the aka super again lisa thank you thank you um and oh
my gosh okay for behind the scenes stuff like um i want to
say a huge shout out to the people i contacted contacted to
make the secret wrestlers because like uh like for like
betel 2 uh mint matara uh and yusun like a huge shout out to
the two uh the two people i contacted um let me see i i
didn't put them on the credits because i didn't i forgot to
ask the graphics people to put them on the uh to put them on
as on the credits page but it was uh sir wheat sir
wheatbread and snake hiss hiss they both made the secret
wrestlers for uh for all of them so uh huge shout out to
them for for making the wrestlers um what else what else oh
yeah guys i was like keep it secret
i was like don't tell anybody no one can know they're gonna
appear it has to be secret to be fair the mint and Matara
the Mint and Matara wrestlers were super last minute like
literally like a day and a day before they debuted and so
like huge shout out for them to to make those to make the
wrestlers because they were literally like done they I
literally asked them the day before the day before they like
appeared on stream um so what Matara was a day before yeah
Matara was a day before like the day before the first day um
the day before the first like saturday basically they they
finished it on friday um so yeah huge shout out to them for
making those wrestlers at the last minute oh my gosh my
voice is slowly die and yeah nda is like trust me source me
Don't leak source me I mean if they leak it then I would
know Because I literally told them They were the only people
I told So like if Because like even people in the server
didn't know Until the day of the event So like I did say
like there might be surprise guests But like they didn't
know until the day of the event started Like, USON got
invited to the server on Sunday.
Like, on Sunday before we started the stream.
And, like, Mint also.
Mint got invited to the server on Saturday.
Like, I think, like, an hour before the stream started.
So, like, I kept that secret.
Also, Beto, too, as well.
Like, I kept all the guest appearances a secret until the
day of...
So, like, if it was leaked, then I would know who leaked it.
I will know exactly who leaked it because I told a very
limited amount of people yes Beto too joined the server like
um um like an hour before Saturday so like an hour before
the stream for Saturday started so like they were all like a
secret um so I A huge shout out to Beto for letting me
invite Beto T.
I was like, hey, I didn't realize Beto T was like a real
person.
Like, are you okay?
Like, do you want to play?
I was like, are you okay with inviting your twin over?
And he was like, so, you know, she was like, yo, that's me
so funny.
Like, yeah, let's do it.
I was like, don't worry about making a Beto T by WDE 2K24
because I know it's very expensive.
Don't worry.
I'll get somebody to make him.
So, yeah.
videos the videos like the surprise appearances with mint
and matara those were done like the day of like the day they
were gonna appear they they the the videos were shown that
my video editor showed to my video editor they like made it
the day of um the day of the of their appearance too because
i had the idea and i was like can you can you make it and
they're like oh yeah they're like are you sure and they're
like yeah yeah yeah we can make it we can we can do it So a
huge, huge shout out to my team.
By the way, for those who don't know, this whole event was
practically almost solely ran by me, including me running
the OBS and everything.
Because I wanted to see if I could do it.
And then I also wanted to see, like, okay, like, how should
this be ran?
Like, how should this be done in a way?
So, like, I think, like, next year, when I do WrestleTuber
2025, again, I'm definitely going to give it to another
person to run the OPS so that it's less scuffed.
But now that I know how it should go, at least I can direct
it better.
I can direct it better.
I can direct it in a better way in terms of, oh, okay, I've
done this before.
Then I know how this should go, how to do the scenes and
everything, how to do the swaps, especially when I'm running
new programs and stuff where, like, um with like guest
caster and everything so like i was just figuring stuff out
on how the whole stream was gonna be like so like now that i
know how to do it myself then like me telling someone else
to do it and like controlling it i feel like um it'll be
definitely easier because i have the better like i know how
it's how it can be done so um so like you know instead of
like you know putting images on live like like like you're
like who's next and then there's like a fucking giant
picture that's like over like that's like uh leaking out to
other scenes and then have to like resize it live that's not
gonna happen anymore right for next year for next year it's
not we won't be resizing images live and everything so so
least like i have a better vision on how things are gonna go
um and another shout out to all the people that created
wrestlers uh for everybody for like all the other all the
other uh participants like i know it's a lot of work because
when people were creating it themselves uh literally streams
would be like three plus hours sometimes so like a huge
shout out uh a huge shout out to the people who were
creating uh the fans were creating wrestlers for us as well
and also like To the character, to like the the vtubers
Because whoever fucking made the Phillion the Phillion
wrestler And made that wrestler flip like 200,000 times That
was so accurate I was just like watch the phillians wrestler
Was honestly one of the most memorable for me Because all
she did was flip She would flip like 200,000 fucking
thousand times That's all she would do It was just It was so
accurate.
I couldn't believe how accurate this was.
She was so fucking fast.
Yeah, she would flip and dance.
Yeah.
So, here's a shout out to everybody that made a wrestler
for, and, like, made it so accurate to the actual person.
It was actually crazy.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Before I talk more about WrestleTuber, I also really want to
talk about Anime North.
um okay so like um i'll talk about uh uh i talked about this
during the panel so those who were there at anime north will
remember what i said then but like i almost like had a panic
attack before before like it started because because i
thought there was only 10 people that had showed up
Okay, so, like, um, so basically, the, when it was like 10
minutes, um, the staff was like, oh, um, we're gonna let
people in now.
And I was like, okay.
And then literally only 10 people walked in.
I was like, oh.
That was just like, I was like, oh, I mean, I guess.
And then, and then, and then I.
wait i was like oh maybe yeah maybe like you know people
didn't only 10 people were there early and then and then i
was just like okay that's okay ducky yeah you're so silly
ducky when you think there's that many people that are gonna
see you and then and then like and then like literally like
three minutes later more people started showing up but then
it went from 10 to like 30.
So I was like, oh, that's a lot better.
I was just like, oh, that's a lot better.
30 people is a lot better.
And then literally on at the at 830 EST, because it was like
EST like Eastern time, like when the panel was about to like
was supposed to start, suddenly like 600 people started
fucking getting into the room.
And I was like, holy fuck, I was just, I was just like, oh
my god, I was like, what happened?
Were all of you just late?
I was so surprised.
I was like, 600, because like the maximum amount was 600.
So I was like, were all of you just fucking late?
Like, what the fuck happened?
But apparently people, there was a lot of people outside.
And like, apparently staff had to give like tickets or
something to like, make sure you guys don't go above the
fire hazard uh like um so like there were a lot of people
actually lining up but then they had to give like wristbands
or something so that's why people were um they couldn't let
everybody in right away because they all had to get
wristbanded so like when everybody like 600 people got
wristbanded they let them in so they let them in at exactly
I was like so sad because I was like, oh man, I was thinking
maybe I should do less conventions because I was like, you
know, 30 people.
Like I feel so bad because they're paying me to be here at
these conventions too.
So I was like, oh man, if I only brought 30 people, I'm so,
I'll be, I'm so, I feel bad.
I made the pay, I made the pay so much money for me to be
here.
And then, and then 600 dragoons showed up.
And I was like, oh, thank God.
My price was just so much.
I'm joking.
I don't charge that much.
But like, but, but also in my mind, I was like, oh, thank
God.
Okay, I did not, I did not, like, like, what's the word?
I was not too expensive.
It was justified for how much I charged to be here.
yeah not a scammer not a scammer because i over like i
filled the entire hall um apparently a lot of people wanted
to still be there but of course uh um like i said like uh
because uh uh we we couldn't have more than 600 people
because of like fire safety so like we had apparently we did
have to like turn people away but do not worry oh there's
gonna be a lot of other conventions um for the jokey world
tour so don't worry guys
i have to sneeze
sorry i'm okay now i had i had to i had to sneeze and blow
my nose thank you i really appreciate it but yes thank you
everybody for showing up to anime north i really Uh, the
very first convention I did, um, I did, um, uh, Azdoki, and
being able to do a Canadian convention was great.
Uh, I've never done a Canadian convention before, so I was
really happy to be able to, you know, um, visit people at
Anime North and do a panel.
Uh, I hope you, I apparently a lot of people had a lot of
fun at the panel.
That's great.
I told some stories that I couldn't tell on stream, so.
If you were there, you would know exactly why I can't tell
that story on stream.
So they got some exclusive stories just for panels.
What exactly?
Should have been in Toronto, bro.
Should have been in Toronto.
Super.
Boo.
Should have been there.
I have exclusive convention stories that I cannot tell on
stream.
name because it's a little spicy spicy as in like as in like
controversial
actual paywall welcome to member goods now you know how the
gray name feels like now you know how they feel okay it's
not that controversial okay i might have like maybe now okay
okay now i fucking sold overhyped it too much like oversold
that story it's not that controversial it's just that like
it just i just i just shouldn't be a story i tell on stream
like don't sit down to their level now you need to tell no i
can't tell you guys just like just like ask the one some of
the dragoons that were there and like ask the that were
there what the story was on discord or something or on
social media but like i know you guys are gonna be like but
it's not the same dokey it's not the same when like it's not
coming out of your mouth well too bad you should have been
in toronto
just go to the other conventions i'll tell i'll retell the
story at the other conventions and then you can be special
too guys.
You can, it's not the same.
We have so many conventions guys.
Just show up at any of the other conventions.
Don't worry, it's not just gonna be in Canada guys.
It's the world tour and the world, it consists more than
just Canada.
So like, you go to the actual pay wall.
What they have to get their monies worth, guys.
The conventions have to get their monies.
worth um so i'll retell that story in the other conventions
you just have to make sure when we're at the panel for q a
and you go there and be like can you tell us your paywall
stories you have i won't tell the story unless like i'm
giving the question regarding like the paywall paywall story
so like if you've never heard the convention paywall story
just make sure you we go to whatever convention I'm going to
show up and then you'll be like Doki can you like tell us
that story that you exclusively paywalled for just
conventions and then I'll tell you the story and then you
can be part of the special club you can be part of the the
special exclusive story club that you would know And you'll
be like, ha ha, I know the special story.
Damn, Collins paywalls, Satch.
What if she keeps making up a new pay?
Oh, yeah, each convention I go to, I tell a very exclusive
story.
So, like, it's like, you know how, like, at conventions, you
collect t-shirts and stuff.
So, as, like, memorabilia for the convention.
So, like, for the Toki memorabilia as, like, each
convention, You collect the exclusive convention story.
The fear.
No, my
fool.
Each convention, you change the story a little bit.
Oh, don't give me ideas, guys.
Don't.
Just like, yay.
Oh, don't give me some beautiful, brilliant ideas, chat.
The photo is hitting me hard.
Region locked and paywall is real.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I need the full collection!
Gladstone, the story involved a certain outfit by any
chance.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I guess you gotta find out in the next convention.
When you asked me that, when you asked for a paywall story,
guess you gotta, you gotta go to the next convention to find
out.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dark, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This message is region lock.
Please view Hong Kong.
Please.
Please visit Hong Kong to view this message.
Thank you.
The super chat.
All right.
But yeah.
Had a great time.
At Anime North.
The hour really passed by so fast.
It just felt like.
Had a really great time.
Just like talking to the dragoons there.
And.
um we had one okay i can talk about this guy because like he
literally is not even a dragon like he there's this one guy
that managed to get to the q a part because a lot of people
wanted to ask me questions yeah and we had an hour so like
one of the guys they're one of the guys that was in the
fucking line did not even know who i was like he just went
to the he literally just went to the panel because a lot of
people were there so he was like i'm gonna go to this panel
because so many other people were lining up and then he got
picked for a question and he was like in the q a he was like
i don't know who you are but like i saw a lot of people
lining up so i came along and i was like wait are you
serious and he's like yeah i don't i don't even know what
question he asked He just was like, I don't know who you
are.
I was just, I'm like, and I called him out too.
I called him out, I was like, bro, you literally took this
spot from, you literally took this spot from somebody who
wanted to ask a question.
And he's like, well, I guess so.
Bro, like, I don't even, like, when he said that, it
actually, like, blew my mind that I don't even remember what
he asked of me like i don't even remember what kind of
question he asked he just he actually went up to the line
just to be like i don't know who you are
boo like it was actually crazy i was like how do you why why
did you why did you come up to line You were this guy's side
mission.
Thank you for the super chat, Meddy.
Thank you.
I can't.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
I was like this guy's random side quest.
It's like, visit a anime girl Q&A.
Um, anyway, I'll talk about, uh, WrestleTuber.
WrestleTuber.
Oh my gosh.
It was so much, uh, it was so much work oh dark blade yeah i
messed up dark blade's name because like he says i thought
he said dark wing i was like wait i remember seeing dark
wing on chat like yeah i know a dark wing and he's like no
dark blade i was like oh i also know a dark blade yeah
i was like wait i also know a dark blade too
um but yes thank you super chat dark blade thank you thank
you i'm gonna introduce myself to dokin she got my name
wrong the first i didn't get your name wrong the first time
you just weren't loud enough so i like thought i heard dark
wing and he exists okay dark wing exists i he he also exists
dark blade you can't just claim all the dark names man he's
real to me they all exist guys where there he is you not see
see there he is there's darkwing see he said hi i can't
believe you ignored darkwing over there he's literally there
uh anyway guys um wrestle tuber oh my god it was so much
work like uh just setting i got a lot of like assets and
stuff like the day before and like um so like for the uh
like Literally the last four, the four hours before, the
four hours before my Apex tournament, um, I was just like
putting all the, like putting all the OBS stuff together and
like putting like just putting everything together that last
minute, um, because I got all my assets the day before and I
was so tired.
I was originally gonna take a nap and then like, uh, do
everything and then take another nap before the tournament.
But I end up sleeping.
Right?
I didn't know I was sleeping so late I think like three to
four hours before the actual uh actual like the apex
tournament I was just compiling everything as fast as I can
and an hour before um an hour before the like you know after
the apex tournament was over I had to still set up stuff for
the wrestle tuber things and I'm like oh my god why did I
decide like you know choice of uh the choice of doing
everything myself at that moment i was like why why did i do
all this myself why i was like oh my god dokey you're so
fucking stupid why did you ask for help why why are you
doing this yourself dokey you can literally ask people to
help you
and but then it all it was all okay it went it went okay
guys everything was okay guys
oh pastoki that's something i'm definitely like i said for
wrestle tuber 2025 i'm definitely gonna like have someone
else handle the opus stuff um handling the scenes and
everything making sure like all the scene stuff is running
okay instead of me you know putting everything together yes
it was it yes it was me running the chat polls too i ran the
chat polls i handled the obs i told the commentators who's
gonna be fighting next i was like the cast i was like dick
directing everything um i put all the graphics together i
told i like told like guided everything scheduled everything
it was on me everything and also like all the other people
that helped too uh we know because of charlie yeah that that
charlie thing was so fucking funny because like but then it
was like wait who's next and then i literally just wrote
charlie versus octavio and like i was like there's no way
that she actually doesn't know who bettle is there's no
i was like there's no way the guest the list the participant
list and the bracket was all there like like i wrote it down
Did I just decide to test her I was I don't know I just was
I just wanted to test her to see To see if like you know if
if she really knew who who who pedal is
It was funny though it was pretty it was pretty funny that I
actually I got away with that I was like hilarious we're
just no it was just fucking funny so funny Hmm.
See, not pass.
I mean, it's funny to just fuck with people sometimes, you
know?
Um.
Um, but yeah.
Things that would do differently for, uh, WrestleTuber, um,
I think.
I don't know.
I don't know, honestly.
Because, like, I know, like, I was thinking, oh, maybe,
like, people should fight, like, uh, you know, instead of,
like, just straight off single elimination, there should be
a felt like the reason why i don't want to do a double
elimination which means like if you get knocked out the
first time you you get to fight again to in the loser's
bracket but the reason why i don't want to do a double
elimination was because it's a lot of time because like
single like single elimination is already like two days you
know we already have two days like it already was a long
time for two days so that's why like i don't think i want to
yeah that would just take I feel like two days is like the
perfect amount of days and like because of that I feel like
I like the amount of people we got like 20 like was it well
to be fair we had a lot of surprise wrestlers so so I guess
it would be like 30 was it 33 wrestlers I think was like an
okay amount to have for um for it dark wind thank you for
the akasupa thank you thank you hi see I told you i was not
going crazy darkwing was real you guys did not believe me
darkwing is real they said hi earlier you didn't see you had
to make that man don't super chat so like he could exist for
you guys that's so up like he only exists for you guys when
he donates that's so messed up dragoons he's a real person
he's not just money
He's a fucking A real dragon It's messed up that it only
took him To super chat for you guys to acknowledge His
existence Like I think Darkwing You didn't have to donate To
like make them notice you I already saw you with my eyes
Sir Weepred Thank you for the super chat Thank you thank you
um spin a wheel to use different types of matches like
casket match and steel cage thank you the super chat thank
you thank you um i feel like for that i feel like that's
what show matches are for i still want to keep the
tournament format i mean like i like that someone was like
trying to do like uh tag team i like that idea a tag team
tournament i don't know if can uh can uh
2k 24 do that is there like tag team tournaments that we
could do that's not like uh because like because if we can
then i think a tag team tournament would be really fun too
in the future um i don't know that would be a thing for next
year but like i do like that idea i do like that idea
and i think it'll be fun if it's like mixed as well like you
know like um you spin the wheel to uh random teammates so
that like um you know people can form friendships over that
a lot really fun thing about it is just seeing all the
friendships being formed as well like seeing uh seeing like
people who normally don't interact with each other uh
suddenly being our like really close friends just from um
just from like wrestle tuber like we already saw like so
many friendships being formed from other vtubers and uh just
like people are now like close friends and they're like uh
following each other and hanging out and stuff like that and
uh i thought it was like really nice to see.
It was really, really nice to see from WrestleTuber.
And like other VTubers, getting to know, you know, other
VTubers and like the the integration between like Twitch
viewers and Twitch viewers, corporate viewers, and indie
viewers just coming together for one big event.
It's been like super fun to see.
Where are you stuffed out?
I don't know.
I don't know what else, what other changes i'll make to the
wrestle tuber format um i think like usually like as usual i
might have like an open call uh to see like it's a because
like mature all the participants um in wrestle tuber like i
specifically reached out to um and asked if they want to
join and i think like um obviously i don't know a lot of uh
i like some of them were like i asked like an like some like
you know I wanted to invite some some indies I don't really
know a lot of the indie community in vtubing because I was
like you know um I wasn't part of that circle uh for like I
wasn't really part of that circle before so like I didn't
really know who were like big indies and who are like
well-known indies um in the community so I did ask like some
people like oh if you have any recommendations like feel
free to recommend me some indie vtubers you would like to
bring along Like, if you have any recommendations, um, like,
feel free to send, send in, like, people you want to join.
And I think, like, in the future, I would love to, like, I
guess, like, be like, hey, guys, uh, if you, uh, if you make
an open call, I guess, on Twitter and be like, if you don't
want to join, uh, WrestleTuber 2025, uh, just please, like,
you know, just throw your comp, throw your comment in so I
can, like, maybe you might get picked, you know?
it'd definitely be a lot easier
it definitely would be a lot easier to do instead of me
reaching out to people and like aligning schedules and stuff
like that well if it's just like comments I can just like
send a DM after like looking through the comments and stuff
but like I do want to keep it like like I guess like my max
cutoff would be 30 would be 30 that would be my max cutoff
because like days was is i think two days is the most
optimal you know like the turn um i like how i do like that
i uh it be my very first wrestling event that i've ever
organized as dokey braid um we didn't keep we kept the uh
the interviews and stuff not that long we tried we tried to
make sure the interviews did not last too long because i
wasn't sure the matches were going to be so i i tried to
make sure like the interview portion didn't last too long um
so i did like that as like a thing i did for this this year
um uh yeah uh be interesting to see what happens for next
year uh perk perk thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you what about hell in the cell tournament match
wrestle tuber was amazing dokey hope to see more Um, I'm not
sure yet.
I don't know if I want to Uh, deviate from the regular
one-on-one Um, if anything, I think I would love to do like
Tag team Um, if I do want to deviate and change something,
change something For the format in terms of like the
tournament format I think like tag team would be like really
fun to do Just because it's like, you know, 2v2 tag team Or
like, like, you know, they tag each other out And stuff, I
think that would be like really fun a really fun tournament
idea because, like, you know, there's more friendships being
made from that.
Hmm.
Um, but we'll see.
We'll see what the storyline will be next year.
Uh, we'll see what it's going to be like.
Um, alright, the thing that everybody wants to know, like
always keep because, like, I think, um, this is going to be
a short stream, guys.
I I'm still very exhausted
I am like really tired So like I'm really sorry I can't do a
super long stream today For like the after party I really
okay the reason I really wanted to do the after party After
the WrestleTuber The WrestleTuber event was over Because
usually after every event I would do an after party But I
got caught uh what's the word uh i think like mentory told
it already but like basically what happened was that min and
i ended up talking for four plus hours last night not not
last night the night before
i lost track of time and we ended up just like catching up
and talking for uh four hours um so i couldn't do i didn't
do the after party and um like i said usually i save i know
you is the story that everybody wants to hear like for all
you guys that's tapped out right now this is it guys you can
tap back in now to hear the story
um anyway anyway so um a lot of guys were wondering like uh
oh like was meant a last minute
is um um so i i think like i sort of like i saw like what
mint said so like i wanted like make sure like i said like
similar stuff so that like i don't like reveal like uh like
you know i just say like what she said already um and add a
little bit of info behind the scenes um but basically oh my
gosh i'm nervous now oh my god your nervousness is coming to
me even though it's my story like it's like my story and now
you guys are making me nervous telling it
um anyway anyway so um like i said um we only recently uh uh
god were able to talk again um uh so i saw like i'm just
like remembering what she said so i gotta make sure like It
says something And
She was the one That Sorry if there's like pauses Because I
had to think about what I'm saying Basically She was the one
that initiated First And I really appreciate that Because I
think I told her I was like I didn't like If she never
initiated, I don't think I would have, I don't think like we
would have ever talked if she never initiated, because I was
never going to, I was never going to initiate first.
So she was the one that reached out first by following me on
Twitter.
And I saw that she followed me on Twitter.
and so from there I followed her back and from that my
management team noticed that we were following each other
again so one of my staff members in my management team
actually sent an email out to Mint asking if she wanted to
join WrestleTuber because it was already announced and I
guess you guys can get the timeline of everything because
like people who like could see like how like when we
followed each other and uh from there like my management
team and then like mint responded back and my management
team like one of my staff members um like gave her my
discord and then like we we connected back from there and
like you know we sent out like we talked a lot like in
discord and then from there uh where we had like a four hour
after WrestleTuber, we had a four hour like, you know, just
chatting and reconnecting and everything.
So that was really nice.
It was really, it was very, I guess like therapeutic to say.
It was very therapeutic to be able to talk to her again.
Because I know like there was a lot of questions regarding
this, but I never got a chance to say goodbye.
So like, that's why I never reached out to her um and
because i didn't know where i was at for a lot of things so
like i didn't want to like intrude or like i didn't know
where i was um for it so that's why uh that's why i told her
i was like if you never initiated i would have never like
tried anything because it was more so of like oh um um i
didn't like i just didn't i was scared i was just really
like i just didn't know where i was at so that's why uh i
really appreciate that she like uh took the first step you
know and uh and then some people are asking um was matara
also last minute yes she was last minute as well uh it would
we i asked mint uh after the first day was over i asked mint
i was like hey like you know do you want to fight matara
like does matara want to join you know like and like because
i was like we do have like two spots here like you know like
the like because i like i realized oh we have like two i did
my math wrong with the brackets and like you know like i was
like oh like that section you know missing and then usually
like i was thinking like oh okay we'll just like grab
somebody we'll just like grab somebody who's like who got
eliminated early on and who got eliminated early on and then
put like put them back in but then i was one i was like
thinking you know like i think you know mint and matara
fighting like i don't know the mint and matara fight i feel
like people would really want to see it so i asked mint if
like Matara was down and Matara said that she was down even
though like you know she was on vacation she would love to
be part of the uh mint versus uh like Matara fight the hag
fight hag fight hag fight sweet thank you the agenda super
thank you thank you um and that's how Matara got involved
into WrestleTuber and I really appreciate Matara for uh
joining as well since like I said And I think she still did.
Oh, no, she came back.
I saw that she recently was streaming.
She's streaming today.
So she was on her vacation.
And so I really appreciate Matara sending in, like, the
voice lines and stuff.
And shout out to my editor for making the video three hours
before the event.
My editor literally made the video three to four hours
before it was, like, about to start.
So for day two.
shout out to my editor for getting that done um because i
was like to my editor i was like can you do it i'm really
sorry like this is so last minute like i was like i'm so
sorry like it was such a last last minute edition and we
just got like we just got the voice lines and stuff um like
the morning of the day two so uh so yeah Like that's
basically how Matara got involved.
Yusun has been, has actually been invited for a while.
Like I think it was like the day after the announcement that
Yusun was invited.
And that was always my plan because I thought it would be
really fucking funny because I was just thinking about, you
know, like, like Yusun coming in with a seal, with a fucking
seal chair.
Like, you know, like I thought it was, I thought it'd be
really funny.
and it was like uh you saw him like message me um the day
because like before then i was thinking keeping it strictly
to like like na participants like na eu participants for
wrestle tuber um but then like we had like you know the last
minute editions with holostars and stuff like that and like
also a huge shout out again to axel for getting holostars um
into the event like super last minute um literally literally
like two days before the i think two days before the
announcement of the event two or three days before the
announcement of the event axel uh got holostars involved um
so like there was a lot of things that were happening last
minute but i think like i don't really i think like uh uh i
didn't think uh um it was like how the word i don't think
that uh rest tuber would be as good as it was without all of
these last minute additions so it all worked out in the end
which was fucking insane because usually when you do stuff
last minute it doesn't work out in the end so so like
somehow everything just worked out like i like as a one man
army somehow everything just worked out
um and oh my gosh yes like the gibo and the taka guest
casting and the guest announcement oh a cute shout out to
taka for fucking jumping in last minute to do the
announcement stuff because saiyu was like you know like he
had like issues on day one with like his own personal
schedule like something unexpectedly came up for day one so
taka coming in clutch literally like I think like 30 minutes
like I think like an hour 30 minutes before the actual
stream stream was about to start like huge shout out to him
for for taking the announcement announcer role there
um oh yeah yeah yeah I didn't know if like he said the Sayu
said anything regarding why he wasn't there but yes he had a
flight canceled because I didn't want to say it because I
wasn't sure if he said why he wasn't there because I didn't
know if it was like a personal thing but yes he had a flight
canceled and that's why I couldn't make it for day one so
like um it was uh awesome for Taka for to to like do the do
the announcement stuff for us um I really it was like clutch
for everybody like I said everybody that worked on this it
was super clutch and like I really appreciate everybody like
coming together and staying up and working on this event
with me and making all
um um uh but yeah uh that's really how it all came to be in
terms of everything um and like uh i'm happy uh i'm really
happy that everything just worked out in the end and like
i'm happy that mint reached out like i said like uh i said
like to people were like oh why don't you talk to this
person why don't you talk to that person like um regarding
like people i've used to um might have talked to before um
i'm just letting them do the first step because like i don't
want to intrude on anything and i don't know like where i'm
at at certain places so because of that that's why i'm step
when it comes to these things um because i don't want to put
anybody in like a weird position uh for anything so like
usually i'm just waiting for people to do the first step
like i um if they if they extend their hand to me first then
um then then obviously i'll reciprocate reciprocate uh so
yeah that's basically how it is
Oh yes Tengen I'm very excited for the collab tomorrow With
Tengen For those who are I'll tell Tengen this tomorrow But
like For those who are there for the story about Tarkov That
was Tengen You guys remembered my Tarkov story When I was
talking about this that still bought Tarkov after this
trauma because it was on sale.
Like, that was, that was Tengen.
Because he was like, bro, but it's 50% off, bro.
I'm like, bro, they just literally had a controversy.
And he's like, but it was a 50% off.
No, no, it was 80% off.
He's like, no, you don't understand.
It's 80% off.
so yes he that was him by the way I couldn't say it but now
I can that it was tension bro literally he called me out on
stream I just because like I like sent him a message on uh I
sent him a message on discord and he was like and then he's
like you fucker you bitch and I was like he he I'm watching
a stream right now and he called me out live on stream he
was like like he's like you fucking because I was lurking I
didn't want like I didn't want to derail his stream I was
literally lurking on his stream and then he fucking called
me out
um um but yes I'm super excited for uh tomorrow with the
apex collab uh with Tengen he was actually supposed to be in
my no key a invitation of hide and seek but because like it
was so last minute and like uh because i uh we had some
issues with teammates uh regarding the hide and seek stuff
so like i had four times i had to find substitute teammates
and tangent was originally it's not the original but he was
one of the first substitutes he he was the first substitute
um but like because of like scheduling wise we had like
issues with scheduling wise for like the og teammates um and
tangent was the original but then because he lives in um he
lives in like indonesia uh i was like oh shit okay Hey, can
you guys, because they need to send, like, the Nokia stuff.
So I was like, hey, my team, my first, this is my first
choice sub.
Can you, like, send, send, like, these things to Indonesia?
And they're like, no, because customs.
I was like, they're like, we don't know what the customs
gonna be like.
Like, we don't know if we get lucky with the customs.
So, so he couldn't be the, he couldn't be a teammate.
because like they were worried that the stuff wouldn't be
there in time did you guys know Nokia's really fucking good
with like Wi-Fi stuff infrastructure like that's the whole
point with this like apex invitational it's the tests out
there like Wi-Fi like their new Wi-Fi thing because
apparently Nokia is now instead of phones they do like Wi-Fi
infrastructure yeah they they they're like apparently like
known for like wi-fi stuff now i mean i did not know that um
so they they're sending us yeah they're sending us like the
why like i have one like i haven't set it up yet uh we're
supposed to learn how to set it up okay apex over yes okay i
found out when i got invited like like guys i knew when i
got invited because i had to research what why we had we're
um but but yes anyway um they have to send out this pack
this like care package which included the Wi-Fi tower the
Wi-Fi kit or whatever um and uh really so it is an bro it
literally says sponsored by Nokia I literally have Nokia on
the schedule damn right it's sponsored by no damn right is
like an advertisement like the whole tournament is like to
advertise their wi-fi shit like uh yeah he got physically
tension got physically region locked out of the game thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you uh neil um but
yes uh so that's why like uh tension couldn't be the
original substitute and i literally messaged uh fun um i
literally messaged fun because i saw like i know who's like
basically almost like all the pro players not all the pro
players but like pro players that are well known are in the
hide and seek tournament this like hide and seek tournament
um because like jen i i originally message Jen as one of the
other substitute but Jen was already taken Jen was like fuck
if you messaged me like an hour earlier I would have been
your teammate Jen Burton by the way um because I messaged
Jen Burton and literally he got swiped an hour before I
messaged him so I couldn't get Jen Burton so then I was
looking through like who's in the tournament and it was like
majority of like the well-known pro players were already
like snagged so I was like so I messaged fun because i
didn't see fun on the list i was like hey fun like uh do you
have like are you in this tournament and he was like no like
fun fps and um and he's like i was like yeah he's like oh no
no like and i was like do you want to do it um and he's like
oh sure yeah i was like okay and i was like can you bring a
pro player because i didn't want to look anymore i didn't i
didn't want and i'm looking i'm tired looking for teammates
so i was like do you do you want to bring somebody like do
you know any pro players that's like not taking it like well
i have my teammate reptar by the way for those who don't
know reptar he's been like he has been multiple rank one in
apex legends so he's been like he's been like rank one apex
predator yes i've outsourced Look, my original teammates
couldn't do it.
Tengen couldn't do it.
I literally had, like, one other sub that couldn't do it.
Like,
so I outsourced, okay?
I was tired of looking.
I had other things to do, like, sleeping after WrestleTuber.
So, um...
Um, so yes, I told, I was like, please, fun, do you know
anybody?
And then, fun brought Reptar in, so I practically have,
like, their entire team, but I'm the new, I'm the IGL now.
I'm the IGL now.
They're signed to Jokey Bird team now.
It's hide-and-seek, man.
How bad can it be?
It's literally hide-and-seek.
Like, how fucked are they?
They just need to hide.
That's all they need to do.
They know the fucking maps better than me.
So they're gonna carry me.
Dark Blade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sorry, I meant you mixed me with someone else.
Not the wrong name.
Also, you considered...
Well, I mean, like, I didn't know what you guys...
Like, I just knew your icons.
should you dark blade you should have brought up a paper and
printed out your icon and then i would have recognized that
you were dark blade i didn't hear the the last parts are
dark but i didn't hear the blade parts so i assume you meant
dark wing because like you know dark wings real in in the
chat so like i you know my fucking visuals of you guys was
your is your fucking icons so you should have printed your
icon and then i would have not mistaken you
Darkwing, come back out!
Show your presence, everybody, so people know I'm not crazy.
We consider a loser bracket next year.
I know it'd be a longer event, but it'd be fun.
Like I said, I talked about this earlier.
Darkblade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But like I said, like the reason why I don't know if I want
to do a loser bracket because it would take a really long
time.
Especially, like, if we do a loser bracket, we have to cut
down on participants.
not no reason but that was the reason why i didn't really
want to do i was like thinking about it for next year but
like um and i was like worried that uh worried that like
having a loser bracket will have will mean we have to have
less participants uh joining in because it'll be way too
long now i'm thinking of a super chat thinking thank you off
topic but have you decide whether you're going to go to evo
thank you the super chat thank you thank you it's a secret
kaz thank you the super chat thank you thank you you'll know
after evo's over if i was there or not because then if after
evo is over maybe there'll be a stream maybe there's gonna
be a waiting room that would be like whoa my story's from
evo but if there's no waiting room after evo then Or I could
have a waiting room for it, and then I just make up stories.
Oh, I should just do that.
Or maybe I'll just make up stories as if I was that evil.
You'll never know.
You'll never know if it's true or not.
The misdirected.
It's not paywall because it'll be a stream.
Kaz, thank you.
Thank you.
I'm not the same person I was two icons ago.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
um i know i wrote down some how is it gatekeeping streams
are free i'm sorry my gatekeeping are while your internet
like how the is that gatekeeping if it's free all right let
me i wrote down stuff is there anything else that i uh that
i missed out on uh let's see no i think that's everything I
want to talk about for WrestleTuber and like Anime North and
everything.
Oh yes!
Merch!
Merch stuff!
Okay.
Like we can get a lot of emails.
I talked about this in the member stream.
I'm going to make an official post on Twitter soon.
Official post on Twitter soon.
But regarding merch stuff, like the debut merch stuff and
the Lunar New Year we finally have a distributor.
We finally got a distributor.
But the distributor is coming over to pick up the stock like
next week and by then um shipping of stuff would start i
believe middle of next month middle of june like i know
we're a little bit like delayed regarding shipment merch
stuff but now that we have a distributor finally um i think
maybe this time like like you know shipping for stuff would
be a lot better now so there won't be like future delays i
hope uh so i hope by now like now that we have finally
settled on distributor um things will not be delayed as much
for future merch release i'm still not releasing any new
merch yet only because i am wayne like i said i'm not i'm
not gonna release any new merch until like the district like
shipment of old merch is situated that's why nothing has
been released products have been released i do have like new
product plans and stuff but like i haven't put it out just
because i don't want to you know prompt like i don't want to
have like so much stuff promised and then like just you know
i don't want you guys to like wait for like 500 orders that
never like uh arrive um and so i like i don't care like i
like i i talked about this before But like if I had like you
know merch releases every month or so that would have been
like 60 to 70% of my income like legitimately I would make
so much more money off of merch release versus like
streaming if I had consistent merch release but like I'd
rather have everything fucking figured out and have all the
stuff situated when it comes to when it comes to like, you
know, making sure everybody's getting their stuff and
everybody is getting their shipment shipped and everything
before I fucking released anything.
Next date, thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
I'm so happy you and Min are talking and Doki.
Thank you for putting on this super fun event.
I've had this much fun in ages.
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
but thank you thank you i really appreciate i'm glad you
guys have been uh have enjoyed it so much um what else i
want to say um but yes but i'm still going to be packaging
stuff on members uh so you might get like exclusive like
signed card being like you you got your merch was packaged
by me because you know the distributor isn't coming until
like next week so um i still have a lot of time to you know
fucking send out my own stuff you know Hey, I still want to
be sure to, like, be able to send things to you guys.
Those who are waiting.
And those who are winning.
And that's why I'll be packaging stuff in members.
For those who have been waiting for a while.
And I know, like, some, actually, some dragoons have
actually received the Doki Gacha.
They've been posting it on Twitter and stuff.
So, congratulations.
You've won the Doki Gacha.
Yay!
I still have, like, Lunar New Year stuff.
too but lunar new year will mostly be um because we're still
waiting on the pillow the lunar new year merch we're
actually still waiting on the pillows um at the moment the
pillows and the acrylic stands so i only have the stickers
and the buttons and the stickers buttons and the red pockets
from the lunar new year merch so like uh i have like i know
like some people have been receiving their lunar some people
have actually received their red pockets already too um
because some of it has been shipped out um so yeah um but i
have everything from the debut merch i have all the stock
for debut merch so i can ship those out uh oh have you guys
seen the postcard from okay let me okay i'm gonna show like
the root the the limited edition exclude it's gonna be like
a little snapshot too but let me show you guys uh let me see
if i can find it i need to do like a really Because it's
exclusive.
Let me see if I could find it.
I saved it here somewhere.
Where did I save it?
Oh, here it is.
Okay, I need to make sure.
Okay, here.
I'm going to make sure it's super tiny and bad quality.
Alright, this is super tiny because I don't have it
watermarked.
There we go.
I'm making it tiny.
You can't steal this now!
Because I don't have it watermarked.
I'm fucking lazy
Maybe I should make it tiny Yeah, you can't steal this Too
late So this is the postcard and the Yeah, but you can't do
anything with it Because it's so tiny Right-clicking it No,
you can't right-click it if I fucking Move it around You
can't right-click this okay anyway um anyway this is the
postcard and the snapshot so um so okay i'll make it a
little bit bigger
um but this is um um this is the basically what the postcard
slash uh snapshot looks like for well the snapshot would be
like a more zoom in version of this um but the people who
bought the limited edition uh bundle with the postcard
that's what it looks like and also like the the snapshot in
the debut bundle like it's gonna be like you know cropped
into like a little snapshot thing like you know this is
gonna be zoomed in a bit more and it looks like a photo and
stuff like that so that's what it looks like uh that's drawn
by pokey one of my good artist friends um pokey is the uh
next time i'll have an auto mark okay i was really lazy so
Next time it'll be watermarked so do not steal.
I will have a copyright in water.
Well, not a copyright because then I'd be lying.
Because I don't...
I don't have a copyright on it.
So I'd be lying if I put like a copy, like, dokeybird
copyrighted or something.
But next time, next time it'll be different.
Next time, I'll have it watermarked so you can't steal it.
Woo!
That's future Doki's problem.
Not current Doki problem.
But yes.
I think that is everything I want to update you guys about
life.
I'm sorry this wasn't a longer stream.
I'm very tired.
But I hope you guys enjoyed.
this little life update that we have today and uh and it was
a great time talking to you guys i had a great time hanging
out with all you guys and just let you guys like just like
you know an insight into what the fuck was going on in
adoki's brain when it comes to wrestle tuber and oh my god
it was so much work it was so it was so much i like like you
know the discord the info it was just me like thousands of
words like trying to make sure everything was organized and
everything and making sure like everything was okay and
guiding like i after every day i had like a schedule for the
casters like each day i had a schedule for the casters and
the wrestlers to be like okay you guys show up wrestlers you
have to show up at this time um you have to show up this
time and bracket two you show up this time bracket three you
show up this will be the estimated time to show up casters
and this is how the castering rotation will be going like
these two casters will be here these two casters will be
casting these matches these casters will be casting these
mess matches and then it was like we i had to like figure
out the plans and everything and oh my god it was uh i i the
one thing i forgot to do was show the gamer subcodes for
everybody for all like some of the participants because i
was like oh if you guys have a gamer subcode because i
didn't want to be like use my only my code you know or gamer
subs like i know gamer subs sponsored it but like you know
we had some wrestlers there that also had gamer subcodes so
i was like you guys show me your gamer subcodes and then
like i'll show it too i was like oh i'm gonna put it so
other people can use your codes uh and um i didn't want to
like you know just be like oh just use my code because like
you know they gave up their time and everything and but i
forgot to put it on stream That's why I tweeted it out
because I forgot to I forgot to put it on stream so yeah I
was like whoops but like because I really appreciate them
giving up their time you know the time to do all of this and
their time to um their time to uh to participate in
WrestleTuber because it is a big commitment and like for
those who are part of the tournament you wouldn't know that
like you wouldn't know like you know like when they had to
leave so they have to make their entire schedule open you
have to make your entire day open because you don't know
when you're supposed to leave like when you're done because
like you know those who are part of tournament they don't
know if they're gonna make it to day two so they have to
make sure their entire schedule for day two was uh was
opened you know so there was that and like a huge shout out
to everybody for just like leaving their schedule that open.
I just remember something I forgot to say about the USAN
thing.
So like, yeah, USAN like message when we announced it,
because I didn't tell anybody what the announcement was and
those that were invited.
So like USAN found out about Restituber the moment I
announced it.
And then they sent me a message in support too.
And they're like, oh my gosh, like, Doki, like I'm so proud
of you for organizing this.
And then I was like, you know what, USAN?
You have to be there.
You have to be a surprise guest, USAN.
Like, you have to be a surprise guest and like to be like
the the fucking coming in with the steel chair the classic
wwe twist um because usad first was like didn't was like not
didn't want to do it but like they were worried that they
would fuck it up type deal they were worried that they
wouldn't be able to um do in a way that people would like it
would like enjoy it from about i was like no it'll be so
good usad it'll be so funny because it's such a classic wwe
twist um yeah yusang was my batista so i i was just like no
you have to do it'll be so fucking funny yusang like trust
me people are gonna love it and then yusang like showed me
like oh i could use like this person and like have a video
and have this rigged and everything i was like oh my god
perfect and they were they they were like the one you see i
was supposed to only have one surprise guest and it was just
gonna be usan and then obviously like the last minute stuff
came up so we had three surprise guests
so like huge shout out to usan for uh for doing all of that
uh for the for the finals and they that they you know they
fucking did it was perfect it was
Like, Musa was not supposed to kick Betel's ass that fast,
because, like, literally I told the person who made the You
Man model, to, like, it had to be the same as everybody
else.
So, like, Betel could have won that, because the stats were
the same, and I don't know how the fuck he got destroyed so
fast, and, like, literally died.
Like, I don't know how he fucking just died.
Like, outside the ring.
Now, people are like, it was a count-out.
He's not supposed to lose his championship belt.
They were gonna- he was gonna keep his belt anyway, guys.
But for the sake of the storyline, we, like, joked that he
lost his belt.
titled.
Like, he's still a loser because he lost to Yuson.
So like, you can't be like, he's not a winner because he's
still fucking died.
Like, he's still he's still, he's still fucking died.
You can't call him a winner if he just dies.
Like,
but anyway, um, anyway, I like how so was like he's always
been my loser quote affectionate
but but he gets to he still gets a belt he he still gets a
belt guy
oh um anyway that was great it can't be a winner if you're
dead exactly he's looking like in the We're waiting for him
to wake up from his coma.
We're just waiting for him to wake up from the coma, guys.
Like, thoughts and prayers for him at the hospital.
I was so angry, but glad that he got the belt.
Like, yeah, like, it was so, like, it was so, like, all fun
in games.
Like, he is the, he, we can say that he is, like, the...
The, the tournament winner, but not the WrestleMania winner.
I feel like that's the best way to describe it.
He won the tournament, but Usong was the event boss, the
final boss.
So he wasn't the, the Wrestle Tuber champion.
He was a tournament champion, but not the Wrestle Tuber
champion.
Yeah, when you win the battle, but lost the war the secret
final boss yeah the people's champ he was the people's champ
um anyway adam you maddest wrestle tuber guy
um anyway that was it was great uh i had a great time um
with everything that happened Next week will definitely be a
chill week for me.
I'm going to relax and I'm going to relax next week.
But this week is still working time.
It's still Jokey Bird workout.
Thank you for all the super chat, everybody.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Also, I actually had people in the comments being like, the
game glitched.
Billion was supposed to win that.
But, like, what happened was that apparently Beto made his
wrestler incredibly dishonest.
So, like, he would purposely rig the matches.
And apparently, so when you saw, we saw him, like, took
those, like, things down on the ring.
The reason why the referee wasn't there was because, like,
the game didn't glitch.
The referee turned his back to fix the ring.
And because he turned his back to fix the ring, that was the
exact moment.
moment that Phelian pinned Betel.
So Betel got a free freebie there.
That was actually fuck.
Betel's AI wrestling was fucking insane.
Like I don't know.
Like I feel like like I felt like the Betel AI was
self-aware.
There's no like I'm I felt like the Betel AI evolved to be
self-aware to a point where that's why he fucking died.
he gained he gained sentience because like like he was he
did okay for the entire tournament and then and like he did
battle things and then like he continued to do battle things
when he fucking died like so so it was actually crazy i i
don't know how the fuck that fucking ai become become 3.0
basically um um so the AI was literally just pedal perfectly
accurate pedal yeah it was actually insane how well the AI
perfectly replicated him um but yeah anyway I'm gonna call
it here guys uh thank you everybody for the super chats
thank you all for like hanging out with me today and
chilling with me guys i really appreciate it i'm tired so
i'm gonna take another nap um but it was great talking to
you guys and just giving you guys insight about like what
was going on with like everything like you know rest how the
rest of tube area was done and all that stuff um again like
a huge shout out to everybody i participated to the staff uh
to the staff that was there um like and everything i really
appreciate all the people that doing like the announcement
like announcing casting um um just doing a fucking improv
and a lot of stuff uh huge shout out to the guest casters
too was uh we actually got real wwe like an ex wwe person
doing one of the guest casting you guys didn't know uh we
got mace from wwe uh guest casting for us and maybe i hope
in restituber 2025 we might be i hope we can get
That would be so cool and honestly, they need the ratings
Okay, that's a fucked up for me to say Okay, um Anyway, uh
Wow The slant If they target the weaves They'll get more
people watching They gotta expand their fucking network guys
the slap you know the ratings are falling guys you fucking
know you don't fucking lie on me I saw people shit talking
about how the ratings are falling so I'm just saying WWE my
email is jokie can read at gmail.com so you want to reach
out and like you know I don't know sponsors send somebody
over for next year bro girl this new target demographic you
haven't the weebs yet guys you haven't you haven't targeted
the vtuber fans just think you can convert a whole new
audience no stop doing is at all time hi all I'm saying all
I'm saying anyway guys uh uh had a great time everybody um
as always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and
move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for
me head to bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody bye guys bye